so talk to me about what inspired you to
make this documentary you're talking
about somebody who's been dead for
thirty-three years who in many ways was
a very New York
/ East Coast phenomenon but now suddenly
makes more sense yes well it came out of
a previous project I was making a movie
called Studio 54
Roy Cohn was the lawyer for Studio 54 so
all through the election year of 2016
I'm watching work own footage in that
context and I keep thinking to myself
this is a great subject for a movie and
he's leaping off the screen he's a great
character and I knew about his
relationship to Trump but then I would
think that and put it out in my head
because I thought well Hillary Clinton's
going to win the election and there'll
be nothing new to say about Roy Cohn and
then on imagine that yes and a night in
early November election night was in a
hotel room in New York actually and then
things went sideways the first thing I
did was go outside and get a huge ice
cream sundae the second thing was I
drank all the wine in the room and the
third thing I did was write the
treatment for this film because I really
thought it was an urgent story to tell
suddenly what we had because I've been
thinking about it before we had someone
Roy Cohn who would have been a bold
footnote to American history who
overnight became a modern Machiavelli
so that story I thought needed to be
told urgently as soon as possible and
here we are and of course you know in
this and of course you you cover the
fact that there are some very deep
historical roots to this this
Machiavellian structure that this man
put into action but let's talk about the
very very origins there I mean what more
the first thing you discover when you
started drilling into this this subject
little more deeply than just the initial
studio 54 footage well you know it goes
way back so you have someone born in the
20s who is a prodigy
and really brilliant person that turns
out but he's kind of a dark spirit from
very early on incredibly ambitious and
he uses his intelligence in a really
deadly way and becomes a part of a
demagogic movement that was transpiring
when he was in his early twenties we
call it the McCarthy era but you know
it's the catch-all for the persecution
of the other basically and in that
period it was communists or Bolsheviks
or pink ladies homosexuals as well you
know there were these shadowy others
that demagogue politicians used to gain
power and Cohen attaches himself to
people such as Jerry Hoover and of
course ultimately Joseph McCarthy it's
part of what the historian Richard
Hofstadter labelled the paranoid style
of American politics and Roy Cohn who is
I believe our modern Machiavelli
posthumously was the great manipulator
of that and he's really teaching
McCarthy how to maximize his
effectiveness in a new era of
communications which was the television
era so now we're starting to get into
oblique things and resonances that
should I believe remind us of current
politics but I thought was really
interesting to go back and without any
overt commentary just lay that all out
so we who live in what Gore V doll
called the United States of amnesia can
better remember how we got to now and
this movie is how we got to now dot
connecting attempt so much of directing
the documentaries about editing and
other post decisions can you talk about
some of the choices you made here both
in terms of animation and the editing
style yeah I mean this is an archival
film with interviews I have another
genre of doc I do which is cinema verite
very different set of muscles because
the persons with you you'll basically
move in with someone and have
the strange transference that's a very
particular thing here you're kind of
building a case in a way it's more si
istic and of course it has to be visual
so what's it going to be well I knew
what I wanted at the outset I had a kind
of film noir a color film noir in a way
tone palette in my mind and even down to
musical choices I had an idea and then I
started to kind of try things out
we found extraordinary footage and we
went through a great deal of effort to
get for instance footage from 60 minutes
that was shot in the 60s and 70s that no
one's seen before and that was its film
so it's really beautiful when you see it
on screen another thing that we heard
was that Roy Cohn's personal archive had
been bought at an auction not long ago
by an anonymous buyer and it turned out
to be a true rumor and I tracked down
the person it's actually someone I knew
who asked to remain anonymous and he
they gave us the photos so what you're
seeing when you see shirtless boys
frolicking on yachts are Roy Cohn's
photos that no one's ever seen before
and surely he did not want you to see
those photos so that's helped for the
elements in terms of the way the
graphics structure is very intricately
organized it has a sort of reportorial
investigative thrust to it and
everything is built like that so you
have tape recorders whirring and that
was created in our studio and then the
graphics are all through the lens of
microfiche so they're reversed you're
seeing them in the negative as you would
microfilm so there's sort of like a an
unprecendented a propulsive nature and
kind of bring the audience through thank
you very much Matt appreciate your
comments